foreign
YouTube channel today we are going to
create a telegram board using Python and
chat GPD and before proceeding I have an
insight for you guys but I want to tell
you like how we will create telegram
board using chat jbt so just give the
commands to the chat jbt and he will
guide us or you provide the code and
we'll just copy paste it and that is
called scripting this is the new in
demand job or what we say in demand
skill like how you can just ask an AI to
get your things done
so that's the new job in demand these
days and the Insight I was telling you
about is if you are aiming to get
certified as an AI and I'm an engineer
and want to build a career in AI in that
case you can check the professional
certificate program in Ai and machine
learning that is in collaboration with
IBM and Purdue University by simply
learn that will open the doors for the
best career opportunities and find the
details of this professional certificate
program that is in machine learning and
AI you can check the link in the
description box below and maybe we'll
pin the comment in the pinned comment
so just check it out guys and now I have
a quiz question for you guys
and your question is Dash is a string
literally denoted by triple quotes for
providing the specifications of certain
program elements
and your options are interface
modularity client or dog string
so please answer in the comment section
below and we'll update the correct
answer in the pin comment you can pause
the video give it a thought and answer
in the comment section
and moving on we will start with our
project
and for that first we'll create a folder
in Python projects
and name it as
Telegram
Port using shared gbd
okay and inside this we'll open the
command prompt
and open our
ID that is I would be using the video
Studio code and you can use any ID that
you have Hands-On
and now
we will go back to our chat GPT
and we'll start here but before that
let's talk about telegram board so a
telegram Port is a program that
interacts with users via the telegram
messaging app
uh the paid requisite is you should have
a telegram account and Boards can be
used for a wide range of purposes such
as customer support news delivery and
even games
and chat Jeopardy so chat Jeopardy is a
large language model trained by open AI
that is based on gbd 3.5 architecture
and geography is capable of generating
human-like response through text based
inputs making it a great tool for
building chat boards
now if we talk about prerequisites you
should have a telegram account python
installed on your system and we need a
python telegram board library that I
will show you where to install and that
chargedy will tell us equal to
install
so we'll just ask chat Jeopardy
to create
telegram port
using
python
okay so it says error we'll just refresh
the page
and ask again create telegram board
using python okay
so we'll see what
any states so greater telegram board you
need a telegram
mode token to the board father yeah we
have to go to the board folder I will
show you guys how to do that
install the required libraries next we
need to install
okay and write this code
okay
so in this script
they have started with the start
function so
it will just says hello
when it will be started
okay
so we will add some more functionalities
and
we will ask where to find the your API
token here so I know like we have to go
to the
code further but we will ask charity
video also
where can we find
the
repeat open
so it states that to get to telegram
about API token you need to create a new
bot by talking to the bot further on
Telegram
open telegram and search for board
father okay and send the board further
message that is Slash new mode and the
board father will ask you for the name
of the board and
it will ask you about the username and
the fifth is the word father will then
generate a token for your board this
token is a string of characters that
uniquely identifies your board on
Telegram so keep this token secure and I
will also blur it so you guys won't be
able to see it okay
so moving to a telegram
we'll just search board further here
and you can see this is the board father
and we'll just click on start
and they asked the HTTP asked us to
write Slash new mode we'll just click on
this and we'll get
so we'll write a new mode how are we
going to call it please choose our name
for the board
so right
simply learn
underscore new
import okay
let's choose an username
so simply
learn
one one underscore port
and it states that that your username
should end in both
so we have landed with board
and you could see the token here and
here you can just access your board
so
we'll get back to our ID
and create a new file and I will name it
as new DOT py only
or you can name it as board.viewer
anything you want
we'll get back to our
chat Jeopardy but before that first we
need to install the library
for that you can go to the command
prompt or you could use the terminal of
your ID
that is
in Visual Studio code you could you
could use the terminal to install the
libraries you could see that the
requirement is already satisfied as this
library is already installed on the
system
so moving back library is installed and
now we'll copy this code
and paste it here
and we will just change the token
we'll go back to board further
we'll copy this token
come back
and paste it here
okay
now we will
run this and see whether our border is
working or not
so it has successfully executed
I will get back to our board father and
just click on simply 111 board
so
we click on start
and see it says hello I'm your board so
it's working fine
so if we write hello
it won't respond as there are no
functionalities so we will ask jgpd to
add functionalities
please
and
some more
functionalities
and this once
to the port
let's see
so sure here's an example of how you can
add some more reality
so they used what have data and
dispatcher okay
when you find the help command Handler
okay
so
chair GPT has defined three functions
that is Eco and what does equal to it
will just give you the same thing but
you give to the board or what you write
to the board
caps that
he has also declared a help function and
in which you can see like what
functionalities does the board have and
the Caps will do it will convert the
message to all caps
Eco Echo the message back to you it will
give you the same message
slash start it will start the board and
slash help to get help
and now
unknown uh if there is something you ask
out of these things it will just say
sorry
okay
I will
let you guys understand this code also
but first we'll see whether it's working
or not
with that we have pasted it here
we will paste our API token again
so I pasted it here now first we will
close this terminal and
get a new terminal and then run the
program
I will get back to the
mode further and this is our port
so we'll just write slash
start
and it says hello I am your board
now
we will say
hi to the bot
so okay it's not responding
okay we just close the terminal and we
have pasted the
Keys also
okay
done it again
now we'll see whether it's working or
not
art
right
oh the code is not working
and just see the code again
okay uh
here we don't have
any response to Irlo
so what we'll do
we'll use the help and to call the help
but we have slash help so these are the
commands for what it will respond
so we'll use slash
help
okay now you can see
let's start to start the board that we
have done help and eco
you put the message back to you so we'll
write
I won't write back so we will write
slash Eco hi
then he has given us the output that is
high
so we can write slash eco
how are you
so it has given you back and same we
have slash caps so let's slash caps
anyone write something in small caps
that would be
greatly built
okay now you can see it has returned in
caps
so you can add some more functionality
to it and before that I will
get you guys understood the code
so now we'll see what does this code do
so first we have imported the necessary
modules that is the classes from the
python telegram board Library
that will need to create our board so
telegram contains the main board class
while updater command Handler message
handle and filters or classes that we
use to handle incoming updates and
messages from Telegram
okay
now these are like we have created an
instance of the board task that is using
our telegram boot API token as well as
an updater instance that will
continuously fetch new updates from
Telegram and pass them to the
appropriate handlers
and we have used context equal to true
that tells the updater to use the new
context based API introduced in version
12 of the Python telegram board Library
and we introduced a dispatcher object
that will handle incoming updates
after that we have created a start
function and passed update and context
so we have defined a function that will
handle the start command
and the update parameter contains
information about the incoming update
from telegram while the context
parameter contains some useful methods
and objects that we can use to interact
with the telegram API
in this case we have used
contacts.port.send dot standards
underscore message to send a message to
the chat with the ID specified by
update.effective underscore chat dot ID
and after that we have created a help
function
so we use a multi-line string to define
the help message which contains a list
of available commands
and then we have used the context dot
board dots and underscore message to
send the help message to the chat
and after that we have the
Eco function
so we use context dot arguments to get
the message sent by the user after the
slash Eco command so to use this we have
to use the slash Eco and after that we
have to write the message and then use
join to join the message back together
to a single string we then we have used
the context.board DOT send underscore
message to send the message back to the
chat then we have caps so this function
defines that will handle the Caps
command and we have again used the
context stored arguments to get the
message sent by the user after the slash
caps command
and then the we have used the upper
function to convert the message to all
caps and then we have used the
context.bot dot send underscore message
to send the message back to the chat
then we have unknown function
that is this function defines that will
handle any command that the board
doesn't recognize so we have used
context.port.send
so it will just say sorry
okay so these are the start Handler help
Handler Eco Handler and caps Handler
so these are the commands
and we have the
we have added the add analog and to
start the bot we have used update dot
start underscore polling
so this is how we have created the port
with the help of python and charge ubd
so
we are done with the project you can add
more functionalities also
to the board you can just ask chat jbt
to get more functionalities to play
music in the telegram board
or you could just ask him how to send
messages to a particular user by the
port only
and you could also
send media files ask the media files
from the board
and you can train a fully board by the
help of charge APD and this is called
chat GPT scripting so with the help of
chat Jeopardy you can just ask him and
he will guide you with all the code and
processes you just have to
like make them in a sequence and use
them too full of your use
so with that we have come to the end of
this session
and I hope that was interesting and
informative if you liked it please let
us know in the comment section below and
also if you have any query please pin
down in the comment section and our
experts would be happy to help you out
and till then stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you